In this segment, we derive and
discuss the Markov inequality,
a rather simple but quite useful
and powerful fact about
probability distributions.
The basic idea behind the Markov
inequality as well as
many other inequalities and
bounds in probability theory
is the following.
We may be interested in saying
something about the
probability of an
extreme event.
By extreme event, we mean that
some random variable takes a
very large value.
If we can calculate that
probability exactly, then, of
course, everything is fine.
But suppose that we only have
a little bit of information
about the probability
distribution at hand.
For example, suppose that we
only know the expected value
associated with that
distribution.
Can we say something?
Well, here's a statement, which
is quite intuitive.
If you have a non-negative
random variable, and I tell
you that the average or the
expected value is rather
small, then there should be only
a very small probability
that the random variable takes
a very large value.
This is an intuitively plausible
statement, and the
Markov inequality makes that
statement precise.
Here is what it says.
If we have a random variable
that's non-negative and you
take any positive number, the
probability that the random
variable exceeds that particular
number is bounded
by this ratio.
If the expected value of X
is very small, then the
probability of exceeding that
value of a will also be small.
Furthermore, if a is very large,
the probability of
exceeding that very large value
drops down because this
ratio becomes smaller.
So that's what the Markov
inequality says.
Let us now proceed with
a derivation.
Let's start with the formula for
the expected value of X,
and just to keep the argument
concrete, let us assume that
the random variable is
continuous so that the
expected value is given
by an integral.
The argument would be exactly
the same as in the discrete
case, but in the discrete case,
we would be using a sum.
Now since the random variable is
non-negative, this integral
only ranges from
0 to infinity.
Now, we're interested, however,
in values of X larger
than or equal to a, and that
tempts us to consider just the
integral from a to infinity
of the same quantity.
How do these two quantities
compare to each other?
Since we're integrating a
non-negative quantity, if
we're integrating over a smaller
range, the resulting
integral will be less than or
equal to this integral here,
so we get an inequality that
goes in this direction.
Now let us look at this
integral here.
Over the range of integration
that we're considering, X is
at least as large as a.
Therefore, the quantity that
we're integrating from a to
infinity is at least as large
as a times the density of X.
And now we can take this a,
which is a constant, pull it
outside the integral.
And what we're left with is the
integral of the density
from a to infinity, which is
nothing but the probability
that the random variable
takes a value larger
than or equal to a.
And now if you compare the two
sides of this inequality,
that's exactly what the Markov
inequality is telling us.
Now it is instructive to go
through a second derivation of
the Markov inequality.
This derivation is essentially
the same conceptually as the
one that we just went through
except that it is more
abstract and does not require us
to write down any explicit
sums or integrals.
Here's how it goes.
Let us define a new random
variable Y, which is equal to
0 if the random variable X
happens to be less than a and
it is equal to a if X
happens to be larger
than or equal to a.
How is Y related to X?
If X takes a value less than
a, it will still be a
non-negative value, so X is
going to be at least as large
as the value of 0.
that Y takes.
If X is larger than or equal to
a, Y will be a, so X will
again be at least as large.
So no matter what, we have the
inequality that Y is always
less than or equal to X. And
since this is always the case,
this means that the expected
value of Y will be less than
or equal to the expected
value of X.
But now what is the expected
value of Y?
Since Y is either 0 or a, the
expected value is equal to a
times the probability of that
event, which is a times the
probability that X is larger
than or equal to a.
And by comparing the two sides
of this inequality, what we
have is exactly the
Markov inequality.
Let us now go through some
simple examples.
Suppose that X is exponentially
distributed with
parameter or equal to 1 so that
the expected value of X
is also going to be equal to 1,
and in that case, we obtain
a bound of 1 over a.
To put this result in
perspective, note that we're
trying to bound a probability.
We know that the probability
lies between 0 and 1.
There's a true value for this
probability, and in this
particular example because
we have an exponential
distribution, this probability
is equal to e to the minus a.
The Markov inequality
gives us a bound.
In this instance, the bound
takes the form of 1 over a,
and the inequality tells us
that the true value is
somewhere to the left of here.
A bound will be considered good
or strong or useful if
that bound turns out to be quite
close to the correct
value so that it also serves as
a fairly accurate estimate.
Unfortunately, in this example,
this is not the case
because the true value falls
off exponentially with a,
whereas the bound that we
obtained falls off at a much
slower rate of 1 over a.
For this reason, one would
like to have even better
bounds than the Markov
inequality, and this is one
motivation for the Chebyshev
inequality that we will be
considering next.
But before we move there, let us
consider one more example.
Suppose that X is a uniform
random variable on the
interval from minus 4 to 4, and
we're interested in saying
something about the probability
that X is larger
than or equal to 3.
So we're interested in
this event here.
So the value of the density,
because we have a range of
length 8, the value of
the density is 1/8.
So we know that this probability
has a true value
of 1 over 8, which we can
indicate on a diagram here.
Probabilities are
between 0 and 1.
We have a true value
of 1 over 8.
Lets us see what the Markov
inequality is
going to give us.
There's one difficulty that X
is not a non-negative random
variable, so we cannot
apply the Markov
inequality right away.
However, the event that X is
larger than or equal to 3 is
smaller than the event that
the absolute value of X is
larger than or equal to 3.
That is, we take this blue event
and we also add this
green event, and we say that
the probability of the blue
event is less than or equal to
together with the green event,
which is the event that the
absolute value of X is larger
than or equal to 3.
So now we have a random
variable, which is
non-negative, and we can apply
the Markov inequality and
write that this is less than or
equal to the expected value
of the absolute value
of X divided by 3.
What is this expectation of
the absolute value of X?
X is uniform on this range.
The absolute value of X will
be taking values only
between 0 and 4.
And because the original
distribution was uniform, the
absolute value of X will
also be uniform on the
range from 0 to 4.
And for this reason, the
expected value is going to be
equal to 2, and we get
a bound of 2/3.
This is a pretty bad bound.
It is true, of course,
but it is quite far
from the true answer.
Could we improve this bound?
In this particular
example, we can.
Because of symmetry, we know
that the probability of being
larger than or equal to 3 is
equal to the probability of
being less than or
equal to minus 3.
Or the probability of this
event, which is the blue and
the green, is twice
the probability of
just the blue event.
Or to put it differently, this
probably here is equal to 1/2
of the probability that the
absolute value of x is larger
than or equal to 3, and
therefore, by using the same
bound as here, we will obtain
and answer of 1/3.
So by being a little more clever
and exploiting the
symmetry of this distribution
around 0, we get a somewhat
better bound of 1/3, which
is, again, a true bound.
It is more informative than the
original bound, but still
it is quite far away from
the true answer.